bakterien sind überall jetzt in diesem
moment wusel millionen von bakterien auf
deiner zuge herum viele davon sind
harmlos einige sogar wichtig ohne unsere
damen bakterien zum beispiel würde
unsere verdauung nicht so gut
funktionieren aber natürlich gibt es
auch böse bakterien keime
krankheitserreger und manche davon
werden immer furchterregende die angst
vor super keimen 33.000 tote pro jahr
durch resistente keime
antibiotikaresistenz ein grund zur
besorgnis für uns alle
was sind resistente keime überhaupt was
richten sie an und warum sind auch wir
selbst dran schuld das kennen wir jetzt
[Musik]
fangen wir an mit den basics das problem
mit den bakterien
bakterien sind winzig kleine zellen die
angst fressen was nicht bei drei auf den
bäumen ist weil das kann man jetzt nicht
so sagen bäume fressen sie auch zum
beispiel sorgen sie dafür dass tote
pflanzen oder tiere wieder zur erde
werden indem sie sie auf essen da gibt
es ganz viele faszinierende
youtube-videos also ziemlich grauenvoll
aber ein körbchen aber auch fasziniert
damit uns so was nicht bei lebendigem
leibe passiert haben hier ein
immunsystem das alle bakterien platt
macht die es wagen an uns zu knabbern
danke immunsystem aber jetzt gibt es ja
noch die evolution im laufe der
evolution spezialisieren sich lebewesen
sie entwickeln skills durch die sie sich
mit relativ wenig konkurrenz in ihren
jeweiligen nischen ausbreiten
durchsetzen können und so gibt es
bakterien die sich darauf spezialisiert
haben und sei nur system zu umgehen und
uns doch ein bisschen anzukoppeln
wenn man so will solche bakteriellen
krankheiten plagen uns menschen schon
seit es uns gibt und der pest die in
europa im 14 jahrhundert ein drittel der
gesamten bevölkerung dahinraffte übersee
vieles bis zur entzündung durch eine
kleine schramme an der hand oder durch
eingewachsene zehennägel das mit ein
bisschen pech zu einer blutvergiftung
wurde wodurch meinen stab ja eine
schreiber war lebensgefährlich für alle
die sagen dass früher alles besser war
aber wissenschaft und medizin brachte
uns eine wichtige waffe
gegen bakterien antibiotika alles fing
an mit der erkenntnis dass es überhaupt
theorien gibt es wie dieser erkenntnis
kam dann auch die einführung der hygiene
und mitte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
kam dann die antibiotika der clou
antibiotika sind hochgiftig für
bakterien aber harmlos für menschen
denn bakterien und menschen sind ja zum
glück verschieden genug und antibiotika
greift und bestimmte stoffwechselwege
oder bestimmte strukturen an die wir
menschen gar nicht haben die für
bakterien aber überlebensnotwendig sind
zum beispiel haben bakterien eine
zellwand die angegriffen werden kann
durch antibiotika wie zum beispiel
penizillin penicillin hemd ein protein
das die bakterien zum aufbau der
zellwand brauchen jedes mal wenn
bakterien sich teilen und somit
vermehren das muss sie eine neue
zellwand aufbauen ohne das entsprechende
protein baut sich aber keine zellwand
laufen und die bakterien laufen bei dem
versuch sich zu teilen einfach aus das
ist jetzt nur ein beispiel es gibt viele
verschiedene antibiotika die bakterien
das leben auf viele verschiedene art und
weise schwer machen dank antibiotika war
es nun kein problem mehr
ein kratzer zu bekommen und tödliche
krankheiten wie syphilis konnten jetzt
plötzlich ganz einfach behandelt werden
antibiotika killen also bakterien aber
das leben findet in weg denn jetzt
passiert das was in der evolution
passieren muss die bakterien schlagen
zurück
leben bedeutet vermehrung fortpflanzen
dabei werden jedes mal gene kopiert doch
beim kopieren entstehen kleine kopier
fehlerchen also kleine veränderungen in
der gen sequenz sogenannte mutationen
die diese mutationen können sich
lebewesen mit der zeit an ihrer umgebung
anpassen also die vorteilhaften
mutationen die setzen sich durch die
werden weitergegeben und durch diese
mutationen können sich lebewesen auch an
veränderungen in der umgebung anpassen
zum beispiel haben wir gerade über
gesprochen
3pc ihn ein ganz bestimmtes protein an
nämlich dass zellwand protein was wenn
jetzt durch so eine mutation genau
dieses zellwand protein verändert wird
und zwar so dass es weiterhin zellwände
aufbauen kann aber nicht mehr durch
antibiotikum angegriffen werden kann
dann freunde der sonne haben wir den
salat dann hat sich nämlich eine
sogenannte antibiotika resistenz
entwickelt das antibiotikum wirkt nicht
mehr das bakterium überlebt vermehrt
sich und gibt diese gen sequenz weiter
wie erschreckend gut das funktioniert
sehen wir in diesem experimente harvard
medical school die forscher bauten hier
eine art tödlichen hindernis parcours
für bakterien auf 1,2 meter langes feld
das sie in mehrere zonen aufteilen links
und rechtsaußen bakterien freundliche
zonen huber nährboden gute bedingungen
zum vermehren einstreichen weiter ihnen
jeweils weil der boden mit einem
antibiotikum verseucht und zwar in der
gerade so tödlichen dosis für diese
bakterien ein streifen weiterhin
dasselbe antibiotikum aber zehnfach
höher dosiert dann noch weiter 100 fach
höher dosiert und in der mitte die 1000
fache konzentration des bakteriengift
was passiert jetzt will man von rechts
und links bakterien auf dieses feld
loslässt zuerst besiedeln die bakterien
nur die äußeren streifen das
antibiotikum verhindert weitere
ausbreitung doch dann die erste
erfolgreiche mutation erobertes
begegnete fällt die bakterien breiten
sich weiter aus bei jedem neuen streifen
kommt zu einem kurzen stopp aber es
dauert nicht lange bis sich weitere
mutationen bilden wird ihnen die
bakterien am ende selbst die 1000 fache
konzentration des antibiotikums
überleben und das ganze nach gerade mal
elf tagen je mehr mutationen bakterien
nacheinander durchlaufen desto stärkere
resistenzen können sie ausbilden
dieses faszinierende und doch
gleichzeitig erschreckende experiment
zeigt uns dass wir mit antibiotika
resistenzen quasi heranzüchten da sich
bakterien viel schneller vermehren als
wir können sie sich auch viel schneller
evolutionär anpassen und das ist nicht
alles es kommt noch schlimmer
es gibt nämlich noch bakterien sex also
bakterien brauchen keinen sex um sich
fortzupflanzen weil sie sich einfach nur
teilen aber sie haben einen speziellen
trick auf lager sie können die inaa
pakete austauschen und weil dadurch
genau wie beim
informationen ausgetauscht wird nennt
man das manchmal auch bakterien sex
dadurch können sie in windeseile rezepte
austauschen die sie resistent gegen
antibiotika machen und jetzt passt auf
im gegensatz zum normalen sex
funktioniert das auch zwischen
bakterienarten das heißt resistenzen
können sich vom bakterienart zu
bakterienart übertragen auch unsere
freundlichen dame bakterien können
resistenzen auf krankheitserreger
übertragen nur damit das klar ist einige
dieser resistenz rezepte sind schon
millionen von jahre alt denn viele
dieser antibiotika haben wir nicht
entwickelt oder erfunden sondern nur
entdeckt das sind substanzen die von
mikroorganismen schon seit millionen von
jahren benutzt werden um gegeneinander
krieg zu führen resistenzentwicklung ist
eine natürliche folge der evolution und
chemie antibiotika wir verwenden
wirst du schneller und öfter entwickelt
sich resistenzen und das problem ist
größer als man denkt und bibliothekar
das ganze ausmaß antibiotika werden
nicht nur bei krankheiten verabreicht
zwei organtransplantationen oder
kaiserschnitten kommen sie zum einsatz
krebs patienten bekommen antibiotika
begleiten zur chemotherapie weil die
chemotherapie ihr immunsystem schwächt
in krankenhäusern kommen nicht nur viele
verschiedene krankheitserreger zusammen
sondern auch viele verschiedene
antibiotika das ist ein wahres erreger
trainingslager auch die landwirtschaft
setzt antibiotika ein und wenn ein tier
krank wird wird oft die ganze herde
behandelt weil die ansteckungsgefahr auf
kleinem raum sehr hoch ist klar ist wir
können nichts auf antibiotika verzichten
und uns sämtlichen krankheiten hingeben
ein rückfall in ein vor antibiotische
zeitalter wäre grausam es würde viele
viele menschenleben kosten
aber jetzt übertreiben wie es ein
bisschen mit den antibiotika laut
erhebungen verschiedener krankenkassen
werden von niedergelassenen ärzten viel
zu häufig antibiotika verschrieben die
nicht notwendig sind zum beispiel bei
erkältungen die wir nämlich meistens von
viren verursacht wo gegen antibiotika
völlig wirkungslos sind weil die ja nur
gegen bakterien helfen dann gibt es
probleme mit sogenannten
reserveantibiotika das sind antibiotika
die nur als zweite wahl oder nur bei
bestimmten krankheiten
gesetzt werden soll quasi wenn es nicht
anders geht reserveantibiotika haben
entweder sehr starke nebenwirkungen oder
ein besonders hohes risiko für
resistenzbildung oder oft werden neue
antibiotika vorsichtshalber auf die
reserveliste gestellt um
resistenzbildung möglichst lange
hinauszuzögern doch leider werden solche
reserve antibiotika auch viel zu häufig
verschrieben ein tragisches beispiel ist
die antibiotika klasse der sogenannten
flur china lohne ru sinologe können sehr
schwere nebenwirkungen hervorrufen was
leider erst sehr spät erkannt wurde
und obwohl wir jetzt besser wissen kommt
dieses wissen nur sehr schwerfällig in
der praxis an noch im jahr 2018 gehörten
durch in rohne zu den häufig
verschriebenen antibiotika in
deutschland immer noch tragen
wahrscheinlich zehntausende menschen
unnötigerweise diese schweren
nebenwirkungen mit sich herum und
natürlich riskieren wir durch den regen
einsatz die bildung von resistenzen was
für nole ohne wirkungslos machen könnte
für patienten die sonst keine andere
alternative hätten zum beispiel
patienten die unter einer bakterien
infektion leiden deren bakterien bereits
resistent sind gegen verträglichere
antibiotika übrigens bekommen auch
unsere haustiere unnötig oft antibiotika
verschrieben schon heute sterben pro
jahr in europa 33.000 menschen an
resistenten infektionen mein kollege
rainer diesen teil auch von der anderen
seite beleuchtet sein video generierende
entkam
das ganze wird nur schlimmer wenn das
nicht bald in griff bekommen
also was können wir gegen resistenzen
tun gegen die resistenzen an sich können
wir nichts machen weil wir nicht die
evolution stoppen können aber was bleibt
ist ein wettrennen antibiotika
resistenzen entwickeln sich derzeit
schneller als wir antibiotika entwickeln
können
deswegen gibt es hier zwei
stellschrauben wie wir dieses problem
angehen können erstens wir müssen die
entwicklung der resistenzen stark
verlangsamt was auf jeden fall hilft ist
weniger antibiotika verwenden in der
landwirtschaft haben regulierungen
bereits dafür gesorgt dass der einsatz
von antibiotika sich deutlich reduziert
hat das ist ein guter trend der noch
weiter verfolgt werden muss denn für
antibiotika einsatz sollte ja geld
nur wenn es unbedingt sein muss können
wir uns auch nicht vor der frage drücken
wie viel fleisch oder tierprodukte
müssen denn unbedingt sein auch in
arztpraxen dürfen antibiotika nicht
einfach auf verdacht gegen erkältungen
verschrieben werden und umfragen haben
ergeben dass patienten sogar oft
erwarten dass sie bei einer erkältung
antibiotika vom arzt bekommen nein
erwartet dass nicht freunde seid froh
wenn der arzt sagt dass sie keine
antibiotika braucht gehe lieber ins bett
und trinken tee dasselbe gilt natürlich
auch für die freunde erwähnten
reserveantibiotika im april wurden
deutsche ärzte und einem sogenannten
rote hand brief endlich offiziell dazu
aufgefordert die gefährlichen flur kino
lohne nur noch im einzelfall und nach
gründlicher abwägung zu verschreiben
doch solche aufforderungen müssen auch
konsequenter durchgeführt werden schon
zu hause gilt antibiotika niemals in der
toilette entsorgen sondern auch uns
gemäß infos dazu in der video
beschreibung von unserem wasser video
wisst ihr vielleicht noch dass
medikamente sowieso nicht im abfluss
verloren haben weil sie so in der natur
landen aber im hinblick auf die
resistenzen verschärft sich diese
probleme hier noch und bevor jetzt denkt
gut in solchen abwässern sind die
antibiotika aber stark verdünnt genau
das ist ja das problem kommen wir zurück
zu dieser studie
bakterien können starke resistenzen wie
jetzt hier in der mitte gegen die 1000
fache konzentration des antibiotikums
nur entwickeln wenn sich mehrere
aufeinanderfolgende mutationen bilden
wiederholten die forscher das experiment
von null auf 1000 dann schafften die
bakterien es gar nicht solche
resistenzen auf einmal auszubilden
gerade geringe konzentrationen von
antibiotika ermöglichen es bakterien
schrittweise resistenz aufzubauen und
antibiotika gelang ja auch normal ins
klo denn wenn du welche nehmen wir einen
teil davon verstoffwechseln der rest
wird einfach wieder ausgeschieden sei es
gerade bei krankenhäuser sind die
abwässer nicht nur voller erreger
sondern auch voller antibiotika und auch
außerhalb der reichweite von patienten
zum beispiel irgendwo im abflussrohr von
einem waschbecken können sich resistente
keime bilden und von dort auch
irgendwann wieder zu uns zurück gelangen
das heißt auch einen solchen stellen
kann man neue hygiene maßstäbe schaffen
es gibt also verschiedene maßnahmen mit
denen wir antibiotikaresistenzen
eindämmen
für die umsetzung sorgen aktionspläne
wie da die deutsche antibiotikaresistenz
strategie sehr wichtige initiative die
auch bereits erfolg gezeigt hat und sie
ihren sechs zielen ist auch forschung
und entwicklung unterstützen denn ein
wettlauf gilt nicht nur resistenzen
verlangsamen sondern auch schneller neue
medikamente entwickeln ein grund warum
wenige neue antibiotika auf den markt
kommen ist antibiotika sind nicht
wirtschaftlich stelle vor ihr leitet
einen pharmakonzern und steckt
milliarden in die entwicklung eines
neuen antibiotikums kommt damit durch
und am ende sagt die zulassungsbehörde
sehr schön das funktioniert so gut dass
wird jetzt ein ganz neues wichtiges
antibiotikum soll so ein wenig wie
möglich verkauft werden nur wenn es
unbedingt sein muss und am besten gar
nicht überhaupt sind antibiotika
generell nicht sehr lukrativ weil die
therapie meistens schnell erfolgreich
abgeschlossen ist so gibt es wenig
anreize geld und zeit in die entwicklung
von medikamenten zu stecken und das ist
ein schönes beispiel dafür dass der
markt eben nicht alles regelt wenn wir
die entwicklung von antibiotika nicht
mit öffentlichen geldern fördern
verlieren wir das wettrennen gegen die
bakterien auch forschung an alternativen
konzepten wie zum beispiel
bakteriophagen oder antikörper muss
weiter gefördert werden deswegen sind in
den letzten jahren einige internationale
programme gestartet die helfen genau
solche forschung zu finanzieren
auch deutschland beteiligt sich daran
richtig so und natürlich ist auch
aufklärung ein ganz wichtiger schlüssel
zur verbesserung deswegen hoffe ich dass
wir mit diesem video ein bisschen dazu
beitragen konnten und freue mich
natürlich wenn ihr dieses video auch
teilt ziemlich viele neue freunde der
sonne hier dabei die wahrscheinlich noch
gar nicht wissen warum sie freunde der
sonne sind also kurze erklärung
jeder der diesen kanal schaut ist
automatisch ein freund der sonne
herzlich willkommen selbst solch einen
keks guter zeitpunkt jetzt auch um team
vorschläge zu sammeln
wenn ihr ein interessantes thema habt
zudem gerne mal ein mal im video sehen
wollt also zu dem er die
wissenschaftlichen hintergründe wissen
wollt schreibt in die kommentare bei
social media könnt ihr euch auch mit mir
vernetzen und schauen was ich sonst noch
so machen wir sehen uns nächste woche
bis dahin bleibt sicher